- "The drunk man responds,
'Why, are you a lawyer?'
To which the man replies,
'No, I'm a (beep).'"
(Devin laughs)
(whimsical music)
- No matter where I go,
people just sit down
and read mean lawyer jokes to me.
- Oh, Devin, I'm so glad you're here.
Listen, I got some more here.
Check this out, check this out.
(cool rock music)
"What happened when the
semicolon broke grammar laws?"
- What happened?
- "It was given two
consecutive sentences."
Duh? No?
Yeah? Maybe?
Okay, no, maybe they aren't...
Here, we got more.
We got more.
(cool rock music)
"We've had a horrible winter this year.
It was so cold, lawyers
were walking around
with their hands in their own pockets."
- Okay, hold on.
When you need a lawyer,
you are incredibly happy
to pay them what they are asking for.
That's not fair.
(cool rock music)
- And listen, I don't make the rules.
Okay, how about this one?
I mean, I don't know even why...
I just found these lying around.
These are everywhere at this resort.
- All right, tell me about it, man.
- How do you... Sorry.
"How do you make a group of
lawyers smile for a photo?"
This is important on vacation.
- How do you make a group of
lawyers smile for a photo?
- Ready? Here we go.
"Just say, 'Fees!'"
- Fees!
A bargain at any price.
(cool rock music)
- "I heard you can get
lawyers at IKEA now.
They're very affordable, but you have to
build your own case."
- Well, I mean, that's not true.
A lawyer will definitely
build a case for you.
- Objection!
- [Phoenix] Objection!
- No, I just always wanted to do it.
I'm so sorry.
(cool rock music)
- Sam!
- Hey!
- I'm so happy to see you.
- Hey, how's it going?
Shut up.
"What is the difference
between a cat and a comma?"
- What's the difference
between a cat and a comma?
- "One has claws at the end of its paws,
and the other is a pause
at the end of a clause."
- You're gonna have to
do better than that.
(cool rock music)
- Okay, okay.
I got a novel for you.
- Okay.
- "A young lawyer passed the bar exam
and decided to get his
first tailor-made suit."
- Okay, hopefully Indochino.
Indochino.
- "So he went to the finest tailor in town
and got measured for a suit.
A week later, he went in
for his first fitting.
He put on the suit and looked fabulous.
He felt that in this suit,
he will come across as very professional."
- [Devin] Okay.
- "As he was preening himself
in front of the mirror,
he reached down to put
his hands in the pockets
and to his surprise he noticed
that there were no pockets.
He mentioned this to the
tailor, who asked him,
'Didn't you tell me you're a lawyer?'
The young man answered, 'Yes, I did.'
To this the tailor said, 'Who ever heard
of a lawyer with his hands
in his own pockets?'"
- Oh, man! Come on now.
- That's 'cause you charge too much.
- I charge a very reasonable rate.
- Yeah, in your opinion.
(Devin laughs)
(cool rock music)
- Okay, Devin.
- Yes, sir.
- "If your mother-in-law
and a lawyer were drowning
and you had to choose,
would you go to lunch or a movie?"
(Devin laughs)
- Well, as we've covered
many times on this channel,
if they're drowning on their own accord,
you have no obligation to save them.
I mean, you should at
least save the lawyer
because lawyers contribute to society.
- You wanna go for a swim?
- Will you help me?
- No. I have no legal obligation, Devin.
- [Phoenix] Take that!
(cool rock music)
- "A man needing some legal
help walks into a law firm."
- Okay.
- "He asks an attorney,
'If I give you $300
to help answer two legal questions I have,
will you help me?'
The attorney replies, 'Sure,
what's the other question?'"
- Nice, nice.
Actually, that's just
reading the textual evidence.
That's perfectly acceptable.
- Says the lawyer.
- Absolutely.
Get outta here.
(cool rock music)
(Thomas exhales)
Oh, Thomas!
It's so good to see you.
- Hi, Devin.
- Hello.
You're my friend.
- Maybe.
- Oh.
Who gave you a lav mic?
- I don't know.
I stole it from Matt, actually.
He might be hurt later.
- We need to have some words.
- Don't sue me.
Get this: "A drunk man walks
into a bar looking for a fight,
so he stands up in front
of the bar and yells out,
'All lawyers are (beep)!'"
- Oh, that's mean.
- "The bar falls silent for a few seconds
before a man finally
gets up from his table.
He taps the drunk man on the shoulder,
says, 'Take that back.'
The drunk man responds,
'Why, are you a lawyer?'
To which the man replies,
'No, I'm a (beep).'"
(Devin laughs)
- Look, not all lawyers are (beep).
That's just not fair.
I mean, you know, professional courtesy,
sharks and all that.
- You're gonna need a bigger boat.
(cool rock music)
- "Did you hear about the new sushi bar
that caters exclusively to lawyers?"
- I haven't heard about this sushi bar.
- "It's called Sosumi."
- That seems on the cusp.
We'll see if that makes it or not.
I'm not sure.
(cool rock music)
- "A lawyer dies in his sleep
and arrives at the gates of heaven,
and he asks St. Peter..."
- Yes.
- "'Why am I here?
I was healthy and so young.'
St. Peter replies, 'Young?
You were 103 years old!'
Lawyer says, 'What?
No! I was 36!'
St. Peter looks at his ledger and says,
'I see the problem.
We were going by hours billed.'"
(Devin laughs)
- So that's actually a huge issue.
If you bill more hours
than you actually work,
you can be disbarred for that.
- Maybe St. Peter has the trap door, too.
- Yeah, I think there's
a lawyer trap door there.
That's one of the few lawyers
who doesn't deserve to get into heaven.
I'll cop to that, I'll cop to that.
(cool rock music)
- "What is the most common
outfit for lawyers to wear?"
- I assume it's a suit.
- "A lawsuit."
- Ba, ba-dum-tss.
(cool rock music)
- Hi, Devin.
- Patch from TierZoo!
- How's it going, Mr. Eagle?
- We just did a collaboration.
You'll be my friend.
- Yeah.
Sure, we'll see about that.
- I think someone gave you
some mean lawyer jokes.
- Yeah, we even got some
ones with animal themes,
so it's perfect.
(both laugh)
"What did the lawyer use
when he went fishing?"
- What did the lawyer use?
- "Debate."
- Ah! I like that one.
That's a good one.
(Patch laughs)
That is a genuine lawyer skill,
and it kinda puts lawyers in a nice light.
- There you go.
- Thank you, Patch.
I needed that one.
- Any time.
(cool rock music)
"What do you call a snake that
works for the government?"
- I don't like where this one is going.
What do you call a snake that
works for the government?
- "A civil serpent."
(Devin laughs)
- I'm okay with a good pun.
That, I'm okay with that.
I'm just gonna spike the camera.
(cool rock music)
- "What's the difference between
the law and an ice cube?"
- What is the difference
between the law and an ice cube?
- "One is justice and
the other is just ice."
I feel like this one's better written out
than to say out loud.
(both laugh)
- We'll put that on the screen.
- Yeah.
- "Justice" and "just ice."
(cool rock music)
- "What do you get if you send
the Godfather to law school?"
- What do you get?
- "An offer you can't understand."
(Devin laughs)
- I mean, for that, you need lawyers
that can write very clearly
and succinctly, and yeah.
I think Don Corleone would
be a really terrible lawyer.
- He'd be a tough one.
- Tom Hagen, though, really good lawyer.
(cool rock music)
Joe Scott!
- Devin.
- You're gonna be mean just
like everybody else, aren't you?
- Yes, I brought my specs
to roast you appropriately.
"Arguing with a lawyer is
like wrestling a pig in mud.
Sooner or later you
realize, they like it."
- We do. We really, really do.
That's not even a joke.
(cool rock music)
- "During a party, a
doctor's telling a lawyer
that he's sick of his friends
asking him for medical advice.
The lawyer says, 'Just do what I do
and leave a bill in their mailbox.'
The doctor decides he'll give it a try
and thanks his lawyer friend,
and then when he gets home,
he has a bill in his
mailbox from his lawyer."
(Devin laughs)
- I wish I could get away with that.
I give out so much good
advice to all of my friends,
whether they want it or not.
- Well, nobody likes a
lawyer until you need one.
- Exactly.
- You know?
And then they're your best friend.
- Hopefully they like
the lawyers before that.
(cool rock music)
- "If a lawyer gets a
hip replacement surgery,
do they call that procedure a rebuttal?"
- I like that.
- A re-butt-al.
- Yes, right, yeah.
You're replacing your butt.
- Yeah.
- I like it. That's a good one.
- All right.
- That's a good pun.
- Well, I just got roasted so hard,
I'm going to have to change my
shirt and probably my shorts,
but luckily, I am wearing
the insanely comfortable
and breathable Mack
Weldon from head to toe.
You might have heard
about Mack Weldon's incredible
boxer briefs, including
their ridiculously comfortable
stealth boxer briefs,
which I am wearing right now,
which I am not going to show you.
But if you are an adult,
you deserve to have
some actually comfortable
summer leisurewear
like Mack Weldon, because
when I'm not in court,
I'm usually wearing something like this:
a super comfortable, breathable polo,
like this one from Mack Weldon,
or their jogger radius pants, which,
it's just frankly way too hot
to be wearing those right now,
especially when your supposed friends
are roasting the crap out of you.
So when I order them, I
order them in multiple sizes.
I keep the ones that fit perfectly
and send back the ones that don't.
So if you Legal Eagles out there
would like to try Mack
Weldon for yourself,
go to MackWeldon.com/LEGALEAGLE
and use the promo code LEGALEAGLE
to get 20% off your first order.
You'll also join Mack
Weldon's Blue program,
where you'll get access
to all of their stuff
really early and way
before everybody else does
and you get free shipping.
So you can go to MackWeldon.com/LEGALEAGLE
or just click on the link
that is onscreen right now
to get 20% off of your first
order from Mack Weldon.
You will not be disappointed.
So again, if you would like to get 20% off
of your first order of Mack Weldon,
just click on the link in the description.
Go to MackWeldon.com/LEGALEAGLE
and be sure to use promo code LEGALEAGLE
at checkout to get 20% off,
or click on this link that
is onscreen right now.
Plus, clicking on this onscreen link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it, click
on this playlist over here
with all of my other lawyer
jokes and legal memes.
So click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.